Rohmer Devon would have been very proud
and very overwhelmed to see this
wonderful possession today a tribute to
his art and I looked out the one and I
said gizelle the lanterns are coming in
we ran outside with our Lantern so we
had a wonderful time in terms of this
year's theme of a premier beaten Bearden
and the Odyssey it's like an amazing way
to mix it with both New York City and
the mythic past room our beard and a
black Odyssey will involve a whole
constellation of events throughout the
year and including events at our global
campuses but this is our kickoff event
the combination of Homer and Bearden and
jazz and Miller theater and the arts
initiative it's just it's it's perfect
it couldn't make more sense when a
miller theatre first contacted us about
the possibility of doing a procession
based on the works of romare bearden and
they actually sent us some images and a
book of his work we were so excited
because we looked at his practice which
was essentially beginning with sketches
working into watercolors and then
projecting outward into these cut paper
collages we realized that the final
iteration of his practice just from a
technical standpoint it was very much
how we finished the lanterns so from a
really basic how to make stuff level we
we felt we had an immediate kinship with
Bearden that we could then translate to
volunteers coming in we I think people
took took aspects of their own life and
and made those the subject of the
lanterns we've got Circe as a dog walker
we've got the Polyphemus of Liberty so I
think and I certainly hope Bearden would
have been really intrigued by the
interpretations that people made of
their own experiences of New York City
and taking characters from The Odyssey
and seeing them through the lens of a
very contemporary experience when you're
looking at the people's expressions were
you watching the children and gentlemen
you see all these beautiful
lanterns erected with the lights
underneath of them you see this like
living art just take place Romar beard
an internationally known but always
painting about about Harlem and he was
very involved with community
organizations he loved children he loved
teaching and so I think that Bearden
would be so thrilled to see these
youngsters of all ages inspired by his
voice is nothing it obviously for the
community to see and enjoy the lancers
were well done and the parade was well
organized it was really really nice I
think the whole theme and the
combination of the modern art and the
New York City and also Odyssey and how
we all are a part of this movement in
New York City is just amazing but for
the kids it's the magical experience